my uncles are all into Bud Lights and I
asked him like what's up I guess like
and they don't like what happened
it got cheaper
[Music]
all right we gotta talk about what's
going on with Bud Light because they're
receiving a bunch of backlash for
featuring uh trans influencer Dylan
Mulvaney on the can
uh since they did that six billion
dollars in market cap has been lost oh
my God are you serious how much
6 billion you serious and now like ever
since Kid Rock blew up those uh
let me tell you something dude like they
did not pay attention to their their
downloads yeah I mean Their audience is
they're not really into the transgender
stuff that's why I wouldn't think so I
thought Their audience was like Frat
Boys and like rednecks yeah like truck
drivers yeah you're talking about like
I'm talking about Middle America that's
[__] mostly what they drink that's
what I thought yeah because even like
now they're going to Coors or Miller
Coors or Miller we're gonna see the
mountains brother yeah dude so yeah I
always figure that like places like that
were more liberal drank fancier beers
than Bud Light my uncles don't even like
Heineken or I wonder why they did that
yeah why do you think they did you think
it's just them trying to just so what
they were saying official from from bud
is that they were saying that somewhere
on a lower sector of advertising
somebody did that that without checking
all the way the [__] to the top oh my so
that's why there I don't know if that's
true or if they're trying to like cover
well that's just their story it was
their story it was like they're Flex it
still makes them look bad but they put
him on a candy it's probably they're
like Seattle Department
they're Chas Department
it was the oh it was their VP of
marketing so she actually came out and
they asked her and um it's so funny
because she was like yeah you know
they're they're uh they're like out of
touch and so we're just trying to get a
new demographic and a young demographic
and it was like wow it's like so it's so
that's the thing that people are saying
like that they're trapped in the middle
now because now you can't go either way
like No One's Gonna Be gonna go all in
like you said like now it kind of shows
an insincerity if they back out which
obviously it's insincere from the jump
they're just pandering what was wrong
with just the frogs the frogs were
[__] cool man dude leave the people
out of them yeah
they should have just done the
and do a teenage version of the frogs
for Bud Light that's trans yeah not
trans if they're trying to get a younger
demographic just do something you know
my uncles are all into Bud Lights and I
asked him like what's up I guess like
and they don't I what happened
it got cheaper
so cheaper better yeah
it's beautiful
is she a woman yes okay
so usually
pretty regressive yeah accounts for Bud
Light at a time like this like when
different major sports things are
happening they're usually very active
with posting and covering stuff they're
just dead silence they're probably
Mayhem in the [__] marketing
department like what do we do what do we
do they're literally in the perimeter
going like what the [__] are we gonna do
God damn it yeah six billion that they
lost I mean it says yeah they lost six
billion in market cap so does that mean
that six billion dollars left the
investment or it's it's
gauge on like on hype like future sales
value okay so then like the evaluation
went down because a lot of people assume
and predict that it will go down it also
was reflecting on sales like with people
were taking pictures of like all the
coolers gone all the military or
whatever and it's just Bud Light yeah
I know a lot of like retailers were
refusing to stock it now which I don't
know how big I saw I saw I don't know
how big of a dent that makes though
that's not like a Salesman he was just
like thanks a lot but take the low
Budweiser for doing it now I can't feed
my family I don't know how we're gonna
do it you're still getting paid what are
you talking about yeah it gets like
extra money with like commission and
stuff but still it's like Flex relax guy
like a Budweiser salesman yeah salesman
he's like he's crying about it on the
social media was like first of all relax
you're fine all right this is also funny
it is
crazy to see how like
they were so off on their [__] yeah
like I'm like you guys are so like I
can't hold on like can I get it but it
was like it was so it was not the move
dude because I feel like Bud Light is
something that everybody like Americans
love so for the fact that they do they
love it I feel like it's very popular
but light I see it on every party almost
but I think it's because it's like it's
like a go-to light beer it's like it's
it's just like I thought it was because
it was the cheapest that's what I
thought so I think in La like it's so
snooty that most people here don't like
they're always talking but they also
took a hard stance when they didn't need
to it's like Shasta Cola coming out and
having a crazy hearts dance when they
could just that's what I'm saying it's
like bro like like like like but like
bro you were this
it's just a beer yeah you guys are the
beer name like when you think of beer in
America you think Bud Light you think
cores you think like budweis you think
it's like end up with the stands like
let the sodas do that like with the
sodas be the stands and [__] like it's
all good
beers just be a [__] beer but then to
see everyone gets so mad
[Music]
isn't that girl getting a lot of brand
deals though and everyone's like mad
yeah like yeah there was like a woman's
thing but Nike that's what I came down
on Nike yeah Nike's reaction was the
opposite they were like so the [__] what
oh do it I don't give a [__] yeah but
Nike's in Oregon Portland Oregon of
course they're gonna be like that and
Nike's already kind of we're going extra
trans yeah with Kaepernick and like yeah
Nike's known for them but that makes
more sense for them to say that yeah
yeah that's Nike's thing
Nike's demographic is totally different
than that's true I don't picture guys in
um
the the South wearing much Nike wear
unless they're trainers coastal towns
those are personal trainers brother
that's right that's right it's kind of
weird because I don't wear a [__]
road yeah I think they're more Carhartt
but then again I do see Carhartt
switching sides these days so I don't
know is it a lot of hipsters wear
Carhartt now Carhartt's not
making close no no no they might it's
like Patagonia like they didn't want
tech people to do that [__] but they
just did they just did it yeah yeah
their sweaters are just so comfortable
either doctors or protect people wear
Patagonia yeah that's true but they were
like Patagonia was like stop stop it
it's for hiking yeah you're just in the
office yeah they started denying uh bulk
orders knowing that to San Francisco
yeah dude but their sweaters are so nice
sometimes I wear my wife's sweater when
she's not looking at [__] I'm like damn
nice good [__] threading and what
what about the Wall Street guys is it
North Face they all have those [__]
vests I guess so yeah dude that's crazy
but yeah you would think like if if
anybody's gonna be mad about anyone
Trans on a can it would probably be beer
drinkers like or Bud Light they seem the
most like finicky about what the hell's
on the you know like they seem the most
willing to blow it out of proportion
which is what it is right now but I feel
like if that's a daily staple in my life
I'm gonna be like okay yeah but few
things a few things are like all
American you know what I mean like
that's so so what would be the American
what would be the thing for you then
that would be like a [__] this wow
not much because it what I'll say what I
mean is me enjoying the beer if I was a
big Beer Drinker Me enjoying Bud Light
is way bigger than them supporting a
trans person you know what I mean like
if I was against trans people I'd be
like no but I like I drink the beer
every day like I'm gonna I'm gonna stick
with the beer you know I think what it
is you know what I think it is I think
it is that people are just tired
stop forcing something on every like
stop putting things and forcing things
yeah um
they're just I think they're playing a
game they're more angry at the fact that
like why are you even trying to why just
leave us alone just leave the Drinks
Alone the drink yeah like apple juice
doesn't need to have a message [__]
soy sauce because you have a message
just leave it the way it is because even
the people like here's when you're
drinking the beef
it's like I think they think the same
but I think they're like you're forcing
me to pick this yeah now you're you're
forcing me to be like I I now I'm gonna
grab course instead of like letting me
just like what I like and let me like my
[__] off if kikumon comes out and
they're well they want to [__] do
some animal abuse right [__] I'll be
like [__] you soy sauce [__] yeah yeah
I thought Kiko man I'm gonna go to
what's something that your matcha
company would have yeah dude
we are coming out whoa
here it is and I think uh it goes hand
in hand because we're in Hawaii and we
want to save the turtles so Turtle
flavor I like that Turtle flavor you can
use turtles if I go there and get one of
your matches dude it tastes like real
turtle turtles
don't you think don't you think that uh
Bud Light drinkers would make as big of
a fuzz if they should put a Chinese guy
in the camp
they would be just as fish yeah maybe a
man we
man we can see
they just want an American flag yeah
got it yeah they want traditional
American values is what it sounds like I
said that's like what it sounds like you
don't want to change [__] but each one
like that we need to be more I think we
need to be more um no I say even the
rationale for them getting the trans uh
girl on the the she was on the can yeah
even the rationale for it is just like
but why yeah what does she have to do
with Bud Light yeah who is she it's just
it's an endorsement deal she likes Bud
Light I mean now she has to say she does
who knows if she really does nobody
knows why would that move the needle I
don't know it's weird we don't [__] say
like we're gonna put this girl she's the
one yeah I know a couple of other trans
people that are dope yeah what if they
put Kim Kardashian on it
Earnhardt Jr same demo I understand like
but when the collaboration isn't natural
it feels yeah you know they need it they
should put Brittany Greiner on there
nice dude you know what I'm saying
America baby on a week on a weed uh oh
yeah see we gummies and you're like oh
man
yeah we need something in America what
was gonna get the light back we need
something American let's put a bald
eagle
Garth Brooks what do we need we need
Garth Brooks The Only Way is the liver
King oh my god oh my god dude why don't
they hit up guard dude if they hit up
Joe Rogan and put them in that goddamn
beer bottle they could never pay him
enough for that [__] dude he's got to be
north of 100 million or whatever his
last deal was that's the only comeback
huh damn now what would be the comeback
Florida Georgia Line I know what it is
FGL that's great the [__] cold yeah
Budweiser is going to be America's best
America's great again [__] simple
it's Trump trump beer oh dude if they
did that that might be crazy make beer
bread again let me tell you something
about like you're back baby you put
[__] Donald tdt again dude
you put my boy DT again it says drained
the swamp and you're like oh dude I'm
drinking this yeah that does feel true
though like from a sales standpoint if
you did put Donald Trump you probably
would sell more that makes way more
sense right from the sales standpoint
yeah if you're a supporter this seems
like self-destructive it's like hey
dudes like hate to tell you that's not
your friend well that's what I go to now
or some some [__] like that dude not
that I care I don't drink but then still
it's like funny though
yeah dude they would be just you know
what I have a weird question
represent America they'd be pissed if
Tony lung was on the camera
do you guys feel comfortable
representing the American flag
me yeah
I don't know if other people are
comfortable yeah I'm comfortable you're
comfortable yeah it's nice and warm oh
okay no I'm talking about like you just
don't feel like you know what it is it's
like I'm I was Men of it is important
it's so funny how like the American flag
will make you feel like racist and it's
like wait a minute nowadays but that's a
new thing
no no
that's Chief Vice Regal it's just funny
how like
the race is like embrace the flag so
hard that they made it racist right so I
think we should all just start
representing the [__] flag on both
sides because I think what's weird is so
if I'm waving it to me I'm like this
represents freedom it's the land where
you can come here with nothing and make
anything you want happen that's what it
means to me no one's gonna see that you
put the [__] American flag up there
and this [__] they're gonna be like
yeah it doesn't look like and that's
crazy dude that's crazy for more than 30
years that's what this represents that
depends on where you wave it like where
you're doing that like if you do that in
the midwest God always like bro I'm
telling you right now walk outside with
the American flag everybody's gonna
think you're racist here here they will
but what if we put it on your house
let me tell you how it's going to work
in La though if I have an American flag
Speedo
okay and then I'm waving my American
flag and I'm saying slay that's when it
works
we should all just start repping it dude
did they not celebrate Fourth of July
here anymore oh Mexicans go hard on
Fourth of July July is alive they go
harder than white people Mexicans are
the only ones that I will have the
American flag and the Mexican flag at
the same like pole it's just like bruh
like sometimes I'm like yeah but
sometimes for in uh for Fourth of July
is the only time that I'm like guy not
today you know what I mean like I get it
when you're like at a Dodger game or
something or you're like representing
the Mexico game or something but not
today not on Fourth of July bro Fourth
of July is for Americans you know what I
mean this is nothing to do with like
Mexico or nothing like that this has to
be about this country so you know that's
the only one where I do feel like this
don't feel right you're a real Patriot
I'm just saying dinner [__] America
come on dude respect this goddamn
country there's really such a
pompousness about it when like because
in my studio I had an American flag up
every now and then I'll get some girl
that or guy that comes in and goes
can we take that down wow and they're
white
have you left this country dude so
that's the only thing because I feel
like that when I see it I'm like that
was right and then I caught myself like
that's [__] up yeah like we should be
all we should all be like just repping
that [__] right you don't [__] look
at that and go I'm so glad I could talk
[__] about my president yeah you know
when it's like to be honest you know
when I did that when I went overseas no
no when I went out of the country to do
like uh comedy you gotta talk about this
you can't talk about that because I'm
like oh were you in Uganda not I was in
[__] Mexico dude they're like you
can't talk about this you can't talk
about things
and I just feel like America I was like
dude I want to go home I just want to be
able to talk about anything and I have
to worry about somebody trying to come
we got a privilege brother that's right
yeah we're lucky to talk [__] yeah
seriously
[Music]